donald trump pleaded the fifth over 400
times yesterday after previously saying
only guilty people do it
only the mob pleads the fifth hillary's
staffers are clearly guilty because they
pleaded the fifth so let's back up and
talk about what we are seeing here
donald trump yesterday was deposed by
new york attorney general leticia james
donald trump did everything he could to
avoid having to testify to have to to be
deposed to give a deposition in this
investigation this is an investigation
into possible financial crimes by donald
trump's business including over and or
undervaluing assets depending on what he
was trying to achieve essentially
keeping two sets of books something you
were not allowed to do and as cnbc
reports trump took fifth amendment more
than
440 times in refusing to answer new york
attorney general leticia james questions
donald trump said he invoked his fifth
amendment right to refuse to answer
questions by investigators for new york
attorney general leticia james the
scheduled deposition came days after the
fbi raided mar-a-lago
trump's home as part of a criminal probe
james is investigating business
practices of the trump organization
trump's adult children donald trump jr
eric trump and ivanka previously
appeared for depositions in james's
probe
as cnn also reports donald trump
declining to answer questions stating
that quote under the advice of my
counsel and for all of the above reasons
i declined to answer the questions under
the rights and privileges
afforded to every citizen under the
united states constitution
and yet
donald trump had very strong views
about the first of the fifth amendment
in the past
take a listen to this
the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth amendment oh when you have
your staff right taking the fifth
amendment
taking the fifth
so they're not prosecuted when you have
the man that set up the illegal server
taking the fifth
i think it's disgraceful have you seen
what's going on in front of congress
fifth amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment
horrible
horrible
it's like yeah
well we know that there aren't really
any principles it's what can i say right
now that's convenient and makes me look
good
when years ago it was about this person
took the fifth and that person took the
fifth and you wanted to go after them
you say guilty people take the fifth
the mob takes the fifth innocent people
don't do that now trump takes the fifth
and his explanation is that he now gets
it he now understands why people take
the fifth because he's being railroaded
and it's a witch hunt and on and on and
on and on they don't actually have any
principles whether it's on debt and
deficit whether it's on government
overreach and authoritarianism whether
it's on business regulation or we're
against regulation oh twitter doesn't
like anti-vaxx disinformation well now
we want to regulate twitter and force
twitter to have to publish anti-vaxx
disinformation there aren't actually any
principles and in a way
to you and me
this makes the movement
seem pathetic
and it is it makes the movement seem
corrupt it makes it seem vapid and it is
all of those things
but to other people
it doesn't matter
these right wingers don't care they have
the same priority as trump which is what
can i say today to make me look good
what can i say today i try to get out of
this on gas prices i don't play the
games i don't play the games of oh well
the president is a great participant in
reducing gas prices when it's a democrat
and then i say something else when it's
a republican i don't play those games
but these republicans the games is all
they have left unfortunately because
they've abandoned policy and so as i
said earlier in the week herschel walker
who doesn't want to debate his opponent
rafael warnock he should just start
saying warnock won't debate me it's
completely made up but their followers
will eat it up and they will repeat it
and trump's followers i saw some
interviews with them outside mar-a-lago
they're already saying the same thing oh
he's being railroaded of course he
should take the fifth oh but what about
all those times he said no no it doesn't
matter
trump's being railroaded and that's the
bottom line
so
by his own standard
only guilty people do what he did
let's now talk about trump's reaction to
the deposition
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15 minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below